Stephanie is with us in Iowa
hi Stephanie how are you I'm fantastic
how are you Dave better than I deserve
what's up great well first I'd like to
say that I love the debt-free screams
it's really getting me motivated and I'm
excited to start your plan cool
yeah however I do know that you have
mentioned before the importance of
having a good support system or maybe
some cheerleaders in your corner I don't
really have a great support system so I
was hoping maybe some of your advice for
those of us who may not have a bankroll
of cheerleaders on hand yeah well some
families are just more dysfunctional
than others you know so some of them
actually work against you oh yes I can't
my lot of thawr in debt yeah on your an
idiot you're an idiot you've joined a
cult
and all that stuff yeah so well I think
you'd number one you got to shut that
down and just when you're around them
not have this discussion
because it's not going anywhere good
well the discussion is not going to lift
you up so I'm going to cause we go
forward the second thing I would do is
jump into a Financial Peace University
class in your area okay and I'll pay for
it I'll give you a tuition to go it's
nine weeks long and that'll get you
plugged into a network of people that
will walk with you while you're doing
this that are all on the same journey
you're on and so they're going to be
very supportive the third thing is
listen to this show and the fourth thing
I do is just love what you're already
doing let's play those debt free screams
and as you to offer YouTube every day on
and on and on just subscribe to the
YouTube channel and then they'll come to
you automatically by email every time we
post anything on our YouTube channel but
certainly including the debt free
screams and that stuff will keep you
motivated because what it lets you know
is what you have to do is normalize
winning and when you're in a row the
people who have normalized losing then
you're going to normalize losing but
when you when you assume you're a winner
as your starting point but you've just
not won yet that's a different set of
assumptions than I'm a loser looking for
my first
Wyn and then you see how how that
changes your mindset is glass half-empty
or glass half-full and that has a lot to
do with who you hang around with it's
not a hundred percent people can do it
without the community support so to
speak but man community support is so
powerful so get in a Financial Peace
University class be listening to the
show don't talk about this at all
anymore to people who are not going to
talk positively to you about it and
listen on YouTube and sign up at they've
rant at YouTube hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]